human beings are fascinated with the
astonishing behaviors of celebrities
will and Chad I have prepared three
stories about your favorite celebrities
you must listen to them and write all
your opinions this is celebrating
celebrities begin we've done this once
before celebrating celebrities no I
don't give a [ __ ] what most of these
people are doing uh however that's the
that's the thing about doing a podcast
with an AI dudes he would like for us to
comment on some stories that uh things
that are celebrities are celebrities
something to say about that one
celebrity I don't know if you've heard
of this guy Logan Paul yeah yeah now he
had a match with Roman Reigns oh but
he's a celebrity but he was really good
at wrestling yeah
last week Megan Fox wore a sexy halter
top on a date to no boo with Machine Gun
Kelly Fox stunned on Lookers in a deeply
cut halter crop top in a tie-dye pattern
with a black sweater over her shoulders
accented by oversized black pants and a
tastefully tiny black purse
accessorizing with a a silver cross
choker NGK matched his movie star
significant other in a black sweater
covered in an orange shattered glass
pattern and black and orange drip
pattern pants will and chat are these
famous lovebirds redefining couples
fashion or are they distracting Humanity
from an alien invasion
okay
I mean what the [ __ ] are you familiar
with Machine Gun Kelly and Megan Fox
yeah I know who they are okay I've never
listened to much Machine Gun Kelly at
all nor have I seen any yeah one or two
songs I've seen a I saw Transformers I
saw that one where she's a demon
no Jennifer's Body Diablo Cody wrote it
no I didn't see that um
um I I see Transformers no I see
Transformers Jesus Christ dude whatever
man whatever dude
um the part at the end though when doozy
suggests that perhaps this is just a
smoke screen so that people don't give a
[ __ ] about UFOs well yeah I will I'm not
I'll say this
if aliens were here to help us I think
they would have done it by now
are they here to harm us I'm not saying
that's necessarily true either I think
they're probably indifferent so to even
suggest that an alien invasion is coming
I don't believe it's going to be an
invasion I think we would have already
seen that by now as well
look at this look at if you're watching
on YouTube it looks like my Starbucks is
filled with this
is not passes green tea oh
he's a piss truther
um I can't figure out how UFOs uh relate
to this story uh and I don't give a [ __ ]
where they were they went to Nobu
that's Sushi dude yeah brother uh they
were wearing clothes dude every matched
brother everything is is a distraction
uh for for UFOs
um except for the UFO news that's coming
out what's that well there's just always
new news new reports coming out new
government agencies being formed to
investigate them it was uh UFO news is a
News Network started by UFOs that's dude
my name is [ __ ] bring blap dude you
know what they're they're fine you know
what they're seeing no the most common
UFO sightings that are happening around
military installations are these what
they describe as six foot diameter
spheres with cubes inside them that the
points of the cube touch the inside of
the sphere and they can move around same
[ __ ] going thousands of miles an hour
into water into space blah blah blah
blah blah
um
I find that fascinating it it seems like
UFO technology is advancing just as ours
is as well
[Applause]
two things that bore the [ __ ] out of me
what dudes he said and what we have to
say about it UFOs Megyn Kelly RMG UFOs
bore you
no it's just that I want to see them
already I want to just have them [ __ ]
land that Close Encounters of the uh
Fourth Kind Third Kind fifth kind
there's all those kinds exist
came out in 1979 or something are you
talking about Spielberg yeah Spielberg's
Like 82. Richard Dreyfus making the
Mashable potatoes yeah that was close
encounters Third Kind Fourth Kind was a
movie I think with the Resident Evil
Emily Jovovich
she played a psychologist or
psychiatrist who dealt with people that
were abducted and then fifth kind is
what Dr Steven Greer talks about which
is we initiate the contact through the
psychic powers thank you yeah well it's
please talk about Jamal khashoggi and
Logan Paul some more you're like oh
you're talking about [ __ ] other
conscious uh beings of the universe we
don't care now let me tell you about
Logan Paul versus Roman Reigns hello
who's the boss Stars Alyssa Milano and
Danny pintara reunited at Tony Dance's
cabaret show in Los Angeles but it isn't
the last time Elon out and Dancer will
be spending time together a who's the
boss sequel has landed at Amazon to be
produced by Norman Lear will and chat is
the new who's the boss sequel going to
be a fun jaunt down memory lane or will
it incite the next American Civil War
oh
I could actually make a case for it
inciting the next civil war me too uh
okay I see what dudes he's trying to do
here first of all did you know that
they're doing a new who's the boss I
didn't know that they're done I love
Norman lears me too it was one of my
favorites
Angela yeah Samantha
moner
other child
um Jonathan was his name John played by
Danny pintoro Danny pintoro but uh I
think we are sitting on a powder keg
currently in the United States and
anything could set off the Civil War
including uh who's the boss prequel or
sequel or whatever the [ __ ] it's going
to be I'm looking forward to that show I
think that I don't understand what who
the boss would be I'm sure that the
woman who's played Mona is no longer
with us I know Judith Light has always
been always is she around still I don't
know I have no idea I shouldn't even
talk how to turn especially when the
producer of this is Norman Lear who
recently celebrated his 100th birthday
yeah legendary TV Creator producer yeah
who's done a million things that's
interesting I'm curious what yeah what
is the premise is Tony Danza gonna be
living housekeeper I know it's Tony
Danza it's I think what dudes he's
trying to get at here is that Tony Danza
uh he he he moves back in with oh didn't
he fall in love with Judith light's
character I don't remember the end at
the end of the show dude I remember so
he's he's living somewhere where did
that show take place Chicago suburbs no
I think that like Upstate New York
Upstate New York so he's in Upstate New
York and he gets a visit from his cousin
who's uh who's the character we don't
know his name but he just sort of uh is
known by his friends as Long Island
January 6th oh my God and then he says
to Tony's like you know a lot of these
you know [ __ ] I mean uh you know you got
a daughter and a son you know or no uh
you got a daughter and then she has a
son right and uh you you know they
really care about these kids in their
future you might want to come with me
you know and then he's like oh he's like
yeah that might be a good idea right and
uh then he should he take he goes with
uh Long Island January 6th guy and then
they go to Washington DC and that's the
whole show it's a a single camera right
it's it's more tony Goes to Washington
Tony Goes to Washington if he gets in
the blue van he loads it with all sorts
of uh [ __ ] up weapons and [ __ ] and him
in January Long Island turns on close
he's obviously if I may what if the plot
is this Alyssa Milano plays his adult
daughter she does have a son who is
about Danny pintoro's age in the
original Alyssa Milano suffers some kind
of horrible accident that puts her in a
full body cast potentially paralyzes her
from the neck down and so she now needs
living help Tony Danza takes about
himself I will take up the mantle once
again as a living housekeeper this time
for my uh daughter who cannot move
one half of the writing team who brought
you waiting to die is is has now pitched
a show uh wherein someone is paralyzed
from the neck down paralyzed from the
neck down that's all the one-liners you
know what I mean gets all the funny or
the punch lines she's like uh yeah uh
but but but you know now I'm starting to
see why maybe
um you know perhaps Network TV wasn't
the thing
for you because it's all because you
like the dude waiting to die was [ __ ]
funny that was a funny [ __ ] show I'm
sorry tell me tell me where to be when
to be there Mariah Carey revealed why
she didn't include page numbers in her
new children's book Christmas princess
in a recent appearance on The Tonight
Show starring Jimmy Fallon The All I
Want For Christmas Is You songstress
said time is irrelevant to me and I
don't acknowledge it that's why even in
my book there's no page numbers someone
had to point that out to me I was like
oh yeah because I don't care
will Mariah Carey start a new trend
among authors to poo poo page numbers or
is this the first part of an intricate
plan to create an army of brainwashed
children willing to sacrifice their
lives on command
okay
I didn't know she wrote a book I didn't
know that it didn't have page numbers
and I didn't know that she doesn't
acknowledge the existence of time I do
like that about her though yeah that
makes me like her more because I too
believe time isn't real My Pal ciao yeah
definitely down with uh not not although
you're a very punctual person and you
follow the guidelines of time uh uh you
want to know why I'm punctual why to me
it's an act of respect if you tell
someone I'm gonna be here at a [ __ ]
time and they tell you the same
you do it you uphold that promise that
you've made
that really is all it is for me
yeah I try to be better I know you don't
have a similar idea about that I know we
are different in that way I have
reconciled it over the many years of our
friendship yeah I gotta yeah sometimes
I'm very I'm very on time for work
things but then you know you one could
say that this is a work thing yeah but
I'm generally very on time with doozy
things uh it's just that everything else
in my [ __ ] life won't hold on
about that Brother come on dude if
you're watching on YouTube you're seeing
Chad make Facebook oh I don't know about
that dude and that's because inside his
mind he's thinking well I don't know
about that dude that's because I'm
hearing a straight line you know what
would be cool though is
Mariah Carey uh the next time she's like
at the this or that parade yeah doing
all I want for Christmas uh you know
she's got all the like she's maybe got
some kids dancing down the street with
her and then they all uh they all turn
into her Dark Army of the night hey
Mariah I got a question for you if time
doesn't exist how do you know when it's
Christmas dude well hold on a second
dude Mariah Carey knows it's Christmas
brother because she starts singing that
[ __ ] song incessantly she just sings
it every day every day is Christmas to
Mariah dude because she doesn't know
what time is brother and that's why her
book doesn't have any numbers on the
pages dude how is celebrity news even a
[ __ ] thing man there's so much [ __ ]
on the internet that we don't need an
actual do we need any dude uh input from
uh anyone writing anything from a Blog
to to a magazine dude yeah as you know I
do another podcast it's all about the
Bachelor and as such I gotta look up on
the [ __ ] world of The Bachelor and
know what's going on and [ __ ] you're
looking at US Weekly you're looking at
People magazine these Outlets all they
do is report on [ __ ] tweets and
Instagram posts and then just put the
caption from those things in the [ __ ]
article that's what the Articles become
about where they'll just do a long list
of like here's a all the people that
were tagged in this post and that's a
[ __ ] article I don't really
understand how it works in terms of them
like making Revenue off these [ __ ]
things but they do that's what like
entertainment news is now it's just
reporting on social media
one thing you could do is cover all
these uh all of the background answers
for the parade and no pink
and then they'd be dancing in the
streets saying I don't want a lot for
Christmas there's just one thing I need
yeah and it's to what what do they say
swallow The Souls of yeah startups to
have the brainwashed children lay down
their lives for Mariah Carey maybe she's
printing her page numbers in no pink
there you go
thank you moving on please
here
[Music]